[Music]
on this saturday night the range of
responses to the rapid spread of omicron
from shorter isolation to booster shots
coming sooner shorter incubation period
means that people are infectious earlier
why one province isn't reimposing
restrictions plus scaled back new year's
celebrations in the u.s as covid19 cases
surge our hospitals are roughly the same
numbers they were on the worst day of
last winter and residents return home to
ruins after a ferocious colorado
wildfire forces tens of thousands to
flee over the holidays
[Music]
global national
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
canadians are starting off the new year
on a high that no one wanted record
covet 19 case numbers are still being
seen across the country prompting
several provinces to tighten
restrictions and extend the winter break
but there is the growing consensus the
omicron variant causes milder illnesses
with a shorter incubation period while
more canadians are getting infected the
isolation period for some is getting
shorter ross lord has our top story
tonight
with the number of new covet 19 cases
reaching record highs every day even
those leading canada's response are
feeling the impact the latest to be
infected new brunswick premier blaine
higgs despite being fully vaccinated
including a booster shot several days
ago i came down with a cold what seemed
to be cold symptoms in any way
wednesday morning i did the test and it
came back positive confronting an
exploding case count you brunswick is
postponing non-urgent surgeries it's
also reducing isolation periods to five
days joining a growing list of other
provinces including british columbia
what we're seeing with omicron is that
shorter incubation period means that
people are infectious earlier
from one to two days before their
symptoms start and that the illness
tends to resolve more quickly other
movements gaining momentum fast tracking
booster shots and making health care
workers and the most vulnerable the
priority for pcr tests now that the
virus is overwhelmed testing capacity so
use the capacity you have in the
smartest possible manner and focus it on
areas that you need it the most
responses to the omicron wave are all
over the map from quebec imposing a
curfew and closing restaurant dining
rooms to saskatchewan rejecting calls to
introduce new gathering restrictions
i've never seen a situation where we're
in the throes of extreme exponential
growth where we're threatening
restrictions and possibly even lockdowns
and talking to school closures and yet
the restaurant so full the malls are
full you have people who are throwing
parties
dionandin says the best new measure
governments can take against omicron is
universal paid sick leave limiting
transmission by making it easier for
working-class canadians to stay home
british columbia is starting 2022 by
providing five days of paid sick leave
similar protection for workers in
private industries that are federally
regulated still has no start date ross
lord global news
and as ross mentioned saskatchewan is
one of the few provinces choosing not to
impose new restrictions despite record
high case numbers but as cases rise
there is concern they will cause a
strain on hospitals and the burden will
fall once again on health care workers
nathaniel dove reports
new year's day is normally filled with
optimism but one saskatchewan doctor is
very worried about what 2022 will bring
we pretty much know what it's going to
look like there's going to be a ton of
cases there's going to be a ton of
outbreaks
there were no gathering restrictions
over the holidays in saskatchewan
instead the government is preaching
personal responsibility
dr alex wong says that didn't work out
well last year especially when the delta
variant pummeled the province icus were
so overloaded patients had to be
transferred to ontario we're going to be
in the exact same situation that we were
in with alpha and delta where we're
scrambling
where we're having to do all kinds of
horrible things in terms of compromising
care acutely for critically ill people
omicron appears to be milder than delta
but it spreads quickly more cases means
more care which means more strain on a
health care system that's still
recovering from a devastating fourth
wave saskatchewan ended 2021 with a new
record high daily case count but premier
scott moe says the focus for now is on
hospital and icu admissions an
epidemiologist believes those numbers
will soon start increasing it will start
to go up and when it starts to go up to
do things then is a little bit too late
all the outbreaks that are going to
occur in schools
all these other pieces are you know
extremely damaging to society not the
start to the new year anyone was hoping
for nathaniel dove global news
saskatoon the u.s is ringing in the new
year with doctors warning of a blizzard
of new covid 19 cases while many new
year's eve celebrations were scaled back
or canceled millions attended events in
major cities as jennifer johnson reports
medical experts say the country's health
care system is going to pay the price
[Music]
the iconic ball drop in times square
with one-fourth of the usual crowd all
masked and vaccinated the city is facing
a huge uptick in covet 19 cases forcing
everything from broadway to businesses
to some subway routes to shut down the
new mayor promises things will get
better not only am i physically walking
into city hall but hope is walking into
city hall
but there were no restrictions in las
vegas where about 300 000 people cheered
along the strip
or places like idaho where a large
unmasked crowd watched the famous potato
drop with the omicron variant spreading
like wildfire healthcare workers are
bracing for what's coming in early 2022.
more than 2 million new covenant 19
cases were reported this past week today
we broke our single day record for
coveted missions this is really a
frightening scenario
almost every governor in the u.s has had
to call up the national guard to help in
hospitals and testing sites our
hospitals right now are roughly the same
numbers they were on the worst day of
last winter's surge this kaiser
permanente rose parade float tells the
story of just how bad the situation is
it never made it out of the warehouse
after medical workers slated to ride on
it were told to go back to their
hospitals the new year starting on an
ominous note for those on the front
lines
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up the new year's rush that
sparked a deadly stampede at an indian
shrine
because we shared him with the world
you shared part of the love you held for
him
with us
archbishop desmond tutu's daughter
shared her family's gratitude to
mourners around the world as the south
african anti-apartheid hero and nobel
peace prize winner was laid to rest in
cape town remembered as the country's
national conscience tutu passed away on
sunday at the age of 90.
a new year's day stampede has killed at
least 12 people at one of india's
holiest hindu sites 15 others were also
injured during the crowd surge at the
vashno devi shrine in indian-controlled
kashmir where tens of thousands of
hindus gathered for a pilgrimage initial
reports suggest a scuffle between some
devotees may have led to the crush an
investigation is underway to determine
an official cause
in colorado heavy snow and frigid
temperatures overnight helped extinguish
the most destructive wildfire in the
state's history but the weather is
adding to the despair of hundreds of
residents trying to salvage what remains
of their homes the rare winter wildfire
fueled by a windstorm tore through the
suburbs north of denver on thursday two
people are missing and more than 500
homes destroyed
mary simon in her own words ahead what's
on the agenda for canada's first
indigenous governor general
in a year where canadians confronted the
painful reality of the country's
treatment of indigenous peoples there
was also a historic first mary simon was
appointed as governor general the first
indigenous person to become the queen's
representative in canada in a special
interview airing tomorrow on the west
block her excellency mary simon says she
is used to living in two worlds and it's
her goal to bring canadians together
mercedes stevenson brings us more from
her conversation with the governor
general
governor general mary simon understands
the north it is after all where she grew
up there she learned important lessons
especially from her grandmother lessons
that guide her now in her role as
canada's governor general she would say
a word
it's
a yuinata
and it means uh commitment
key let's keep going
don't give up
and that was always a word that we used
in our family but it's also it's all so
used every day in my culture in the
inuit culture
simon is making history as the first
indigenous governor general and she
wants to be a unifying force for canada
an embodiment for reconciliation a
journey that she says must be
accelerated and engaged in by all
canadians a critically important step
forward according to simon is fixing the
inequalities in education faced by
indigenous youth especially in the north
down here you have
the opportunity to stay home or to go
away the up north or in remote areas you
don't have that choice if you want to go
to post-secondary education you have to
move away
and indigenous people are very
close-knit
family
and it's difficult for people to move
away and especially when
young people
have families when they are quite young
someday her excellency mary simon would
like to see a northern university and
indigenous post-secondary institutions
simon believes the discovery of unmarked
residential graves made the wrongs of
the past much more real in the minds of
canadians this year but she says
reconciliation isn't just about what
governments can do to address the issue
there's also the relationship building
that has to occur between people
individuals and other
you know cultures and other societies
have to
build a better relationship a better
understanding have more respect for each
other
simon was also blunt about her view of
the mental health care system in canada
its importance and its lack of resources
two things she hopes to shine a light on
saying it is critically important under
the strain of the covid19 pandemic and
key to addressing the tragedy of the
high suicide rate in northern
communities so as a country we have put
a lot of emphasis on physical health
and we're able to you know get the kind
of treatment we we need in terms of our
physical well-being but in terms of our
mental health we it's very much
on a much lower standard of health care
and we need to address that you can
catch our full conversation with
governor general mary simon coming up on
the west block mercedes stephenson
global news ottawa